[موسيقى]
كنت اعرف انه ستكون هناك محاوله لاختيالي
وظهرت في وسائل الاعلام واوضحت للجميع ان
وكاله استخباراتنا ورئيس الوزراء ووزير
الداخليه هم وراء العمليه كنت محظوظا جدا
لانهم لم يتمكنوا من قتله لان فتى شجاعا
كان يقف بين الجموع شاهد الرجل يخرج
المسدس فوضع يده في وجهه وانزله ولذلك
اصابت الرصاصات ساقي بدلا من الناحيه
العليا من جسد انا محظوظ جدا لانني بقيت
على قيد الحياه
[موسيقى]
الاشخاص الذين حاولوا اغتيالي يتولون الان
مناصب في السلطه ثلاثه منهم سيكررون
المحاوله مجددا لانهم يخشون اذا فزت في
الانتخابات فساخدعهم للمساءله ولهذا السبب
سيحاولون اغتيال مجددا والحكومه نفسها
اعلنت الناحيه مهدده ولكن بسبب جهات
خارجيه وانا اعرف ان الحقيقه هي انه ليست
هناك جهات خارجيه انما الحكومه نفسها هي
التي تحاول اغتياله
[موسيقى]
تقصدين محاوله ازاحه يعني السلطه ماذا علي
ان اثبت هناك مئه قضيه مرفوعه ضدي والسبب
وراء كل هذه القضايا هو الزج بي في السجن
كلها قضايا زائفه واؤكد لك مره اخرى انا
شخصيه عامه منذ 50 عاما وهذه البلاد
تعرفني والجميع يعرف ان هذه القضايا زائفه
والا لماذا جاء هذا العدد الكبير من
المناصرين لدعمه عندما سمعوا ان الشرطه
تحاول اعتقالي فكل هذه القضايا وراءها
دوافع سياسيه لمجرمين يحكمون في باكستان
وكلهم مدعي عليهم بقضايا فساد
[موسيقى]